in the world of anime weapons come with
plenty but none of them seem more common
than the good old sword but not all
swordsmen are created equally for
today's list we're going to be going
over some of the most absurd and
overpowered masters of the sword that
the anime world has given us and to add
an extra challenge i'll be straying away
by default from all those isakai and
light novel characters because we know
incomprehensibly overpowered characters
are all the rage these days so here we
are my gallery of some of the most
overpowered swordsmen in anime
let's open up with one of the og's go in
one
[Music]
the lupone series isn't exactly the
first title that crosses anyone's mind
when the topic shifts to overpowered
characters but can we take a step back
and look at goemon's insane feats with
goemon the show takes realism and throws
it out the window in hilariously
entertaining ways i'm not just talking
about one man army moment it showcases
his skill i'm sure what makes him
overpowered is how his sword can just
slice through anything literally like i
mean airplanes cars trucks anything heck
even meteors and lightning are no match
against his almighty zantetsukem that's
absurd in an entertaining over-the-top
way if you ask me
next up is another og hiko seijuro
it takes a monster of a man to be the
master and mentor to the notorious
bhatto site but that description doesn't
exactly describe hiko seijuro now does
it first impressions can be misleading
and while he does look cool and powerful
say judo doesn't seem to be an absolute
top-tier fighter well he's strong but to
the point where his involvement would
have quickly ended the whole shishio
fiasco but he is apparently that and
there's no one in ruroni kenshin who can
even come close to this guy it's just a
shame that he doesn't have a lot of
chances to show his actual prowess in
the show it's in the personality after
all he doesn't get too involved with the
story in its events but given that he's
trained kenshin and how he demolishes
all competition when he does show up
it's clear as day that hiko seizure is
the most powerful character in ruroni
kenshin
[Music]
how about moving to something more
modern wait fma has been around for
almost two decades now anyway here's
king bradley
[Applause]
ah the unstoppable king bradley owner of
the all-seeing ultimate eye but a broken
ability does not a badass an overpowered
swordsman make for all the hype behind
the powers of precognition king bradley
as both a character and a fighter isn't
solely defined by it if it were me i'd
say that king bradley strikes fear in
the hearts of enemies due to his sheer
skill in swordsmanship being a
homunculus he naturally has augmented
physical abilities agility reflexes all
of that sort of stuff he's not the
biggest powerhouse the series has to
offer but he's by far one of the best
dualists here being able to turn numbers
disadvantages into easy and memorable
wins then you remember that ultimate eye
i talked about that more or less brings
everything over the edge and you can see
how bradley has maintained his hold over
power for so long it makes his eventual
defeat all the more cathartic and built
scar up so much
we couldn't have this list without guts
too
guts is just the type of character that
oozes badass edgy energy with his every
movement the design speaks for itself
and he fits seamlessly in the gritty
no-nonsense storytelling that berserk
gives us i don't exactly know where to
start with guts because he just has so
many moments worth talking about in the
show probably the most popular amongst
them is the one where he defeats 100
soldiers a shining moment where he not
only shows off his power but his
durability as well berserk's filled with
badass characters but none of them
embody the word as much as guts himself
among the characters we've covered so
far he's by far the perfect raid boss a
pure juggernaut of power and hardiness
afro samurai is a cool one too
[Applause]
afro samurai is not too known but who
else can get a short anime series all
meant to show how awesome he is yet the
whole premise of afro samurai is his
quest to be the strongest and how
amazing he is in the road to glory from
the get go we get treated to one man
army moment after another in a series
that pulls no punches in depicting
violence and how unstoppable afro really
is in terms of having strength it's just
impossible to wrap our heads around i
admit that afrofalls a bit short
compared to someone like king bradley
but that doesn't detract from how
overpowered and badass he is this is
something you must see to believe so
head on over start watching the show's
five episodes and be dazzled at the
might of afro samurai
bleachers poster chart for overpowered
swordsman ken budgie
[Music]
you know part of me wanted to give the
title to aizen or juha from the upcoming
thousand year blood war arc however the
latter's manga exclusive for now and the
former feels like a mage in terms of
fighting however in honest brutal
no-holds-barred sword fights without
deriving into the manga only spoiler
territory for to be revealed swordsmen
and swords women few can come close to
kenpachi genbaity is the series
definition of an overpowered monster
that's virtually impossible to stop
whereas most shinigami use magical
powers from their swords genbachi just
prefers to face his battles head-on
direct combat and getting down and
dirties is jam and if we're going to let
the anime's combat record speak it's a
pretty damn effective tactic isn't it
ken butchie hasn't really lost a single
fight so far will the thousand-year
blood war rock be finally when kenpachi
finds his match let's wait and see
does levi count well he's pretty
overpowered as they come
he's not humanity's strongest soldier
for nothing it's been almost a decade
since levi first graced our screens with
his jaw-dropping feet and it's great
that he's still going strong he's still
as overpowered as they come and even in
the latter seasons of attack on titan
you can see that he's pretty much a
one-man army some people even go as far
as to say that he's the one person
single-handedly keeping the balance of
power between humanity and titans in
check we all know that aaron's the big
star in the finale of attack on titan
belivar has left quite a legacy in his
wake his zeke battles are moments
immortalised in every attack on titan
fans lives and everyone knows how epic
seeing him slice and dice his way to
titans will always be
but hey april is the start of spring in
japan so that means sakura picnics and
flower viewing it also leads to may
which is when the japanese celebrate the
prized first tea harvest of the year
that's why our sponsors sakurako and
tokyo treat are here to bring a double
header for you sakurako and tokyo treat
are subscription-based services that
will deliver you some of the finest and
most delicious japanese snacks
sakurako's theme this month is matcha
and mochi while tokyo treat will be
bringing you a sakura picnic themed box
the two boxes are similar yet different
with sakurako mainly focusing on the
more traditional side of japanese snacks
and tokyo tree giving you a more modern
experience the former will be giving you
a fair share of exclusive tea as well as
matcha themed manju mochi and such with
artisan chopsticks to top off the list
if you prefer modern exclusive and
seasonal sweet sensations over matcha
however perhaps the tokyo treat box is
for you i'm talking things like kitkat
banana caramel and red bean loaf that
you won't get anywhere else i personally
love the pineapple sakura candy which is
made exclusively for tokyo tree
subscribers so check out the link in the
description box and use code vinnie to
get five dollars off your first box i
guarantee you won't regret spending a
cent on this super good deal from the
one piece universe the undisputed king
of the sword is mihawk
there's a good reason to fear mihawk
titled strongest swordsman in the world
his appearance alone strikes into his
opponents a very powerful presence but
wait until you get to actually see what
he's capable of to which he's defeated
zoro handily and you know you're pretty
badass to have dueled with shanks
multiple times with those credentials
under his belt seeing him lay waste to
entire fleets of ships or flexing his
power against gigantic icebergs does
seem like child's play don't you think
the kicker all his feats are of his own
abilities and strength he has no devil
fruit but i wouldn't blame you if he
thought that he had one really
let's save the most insane of them all
for last utsuro
in all my years of watching anime i
don't think that any anime swordsman
comes close to utsuru in terms of being
overpowered we're talking about a guy
who can outright defy death here besides
those gimmicks utsuro himself is as
skilled as they come in combat he's the
type of person who would take on an
entire protagonist party and come out on
top without breaking a sweat considering
how many top tier swordsman guintama has
i mean that's a feat by itself but then
you add all those immortality gimmicks
it's no wonder there's an entire arc
about him wanting to die in a blaze of
glory and having to take the whole
universe with him it does take a whole
load of plot contrivances and
combinations from the protagonists and
allies to finally put him down that's
just a testament to how broken he really
is
[Music]
who amongst these swordsmen is the most
overpowered and badass of the war you
tell me if you're interested in
connecting through social media head on
over to the discord channel where you
can meet fellow anime fans and take part
in occasional giveaways and events also
you can check out the videotube
instagram for news regarding the channel
and the next videos oh and patreon and
channel memberships are always open for
those who prefer to support the channel
through monetary means it means so much
to have your support and it'll help me
make even more awesome videos in the
future that's it for today and i'll be
seeing you next time thank you for
watching